now and thank you for joining us I'm
Kirsten Joyce Robert Tellis is no longer
the Clark County public administrator
this morning a district judge ruled to
remove him from the position Candace
Charles joins us live from The Newsroom
with more on the judge's decision
Candace well Robert Tellez is behind
bars charged with murder he is accused
of the stabbing death of view Journal
investigative journalist Jeff gearman
the county argued that him being a high
being behind bars prohibits him from
doing his job and the judge agreed
the Clark County District Attorney's
Office filed to remove Telus from the
position last month last week his civil
court Council said Telus did not intend
on resigning from his 120 000 salary
position collecting the money while he
sat in jail while also retaining a
public defender well you're not only one
that kicking either two you want a
full-blown part of your candles
now the judge's decision to remove Telus
from the position is due to his
inability to show up for work as he is
in jail and perform his duties now the
judge also presented and affidavit with
an admission from Telus himself saying
he expected to lose his position and
therefore needed a public defender now
Clark County will move forward with
filling this position meanwhile Robert
Tillerson expected to be back in court
on the murder charge October 26th I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now thank you
Candace and in a statement released
today in the County's case to remove
Telus from Office Clark County says
quote in the counties filing Clark
County asserted that following the
charge of open murder in the death of
Jeff gearman Robert Tellis was unable to
fulfill his job responsibilities and was
neglectful of office today a judge
agreed and removed him from elected
office the county will now move forward
in appointing someone to fulfill the end
of his term